You really can’t tell the meaning of someone’s
life till the very end.
And it’s for the same reason, right, is
that how all the pieces fit together in the
story or in the life is not necessarily determined
until the final moment.
And I think that’s part of the reason too,
why among Catholics, for example, and Christians
in general, there’s an idea that salvation
can always be attained, right?
Right up to the last moment, no matter what
your life was like.
And you think: Well, that’s a pretty cheap
trick, you know, because you can run around
doing terrible things your whole life, but
as long as you can get it together at the
last second, then you’re Scot-free.
But if you think about it in terms of a story,
then you can understand how that could conceivably
be the case.
And it’s for this reason, of course, that
this lecture in particular makes me nervous
more than any of the other ones I do, because
I’ve been telling you a story that’s basically
40 hours long, right, and its spoken forum,
and then who knows how long in its written
form.
And it’s complicated to pull it together
properly.
And that’s partly because, as far as I’ve
been concerned, we’ve been talking about
issues in psychology that are more difficult
than any other.
First of all, conceptually, even from a neuropsychological
perspective, because I’ve been offering
you a model of the way the brain processes
the environment, that I think is really novel.
And I think it reflects the current state
of neuroscience.
And - but more than that, there’s the problem
that we’ve been dealing with issues all
the way along of life and death, and of war
and destruction, and of the possibility for
clear-headed optimism, right?
and possibility which, as we’ve discussed,
more or less escaped Tolstoy, say, for most
of his life, right, because when Tolstoy woke
up from his delusions, he looked at the world
and he said: Well, clearly it’s such a terrible
place that, if you’re not looking at it
through the veils of illusion, there’s no
way that you can do anything but stand in
opposition to it once you understand its basic
structure, right?
Suffering and innocence suffering, and complete
vulnerability, and the whole existential mess
that makes up life.
Now it turns out that Tolstoy overcame his
rationally induced cynicism in a kind of mystical
way.
He had a dream that he was suspended from
some transcendent space by a belt around the
middle of his waist, which hung him over a
pit of chaos.
And in that image, he found comfort.
And fair enough, it’s a powerful image.
But it’s not well delineated, right?
And it worked well for Tolstoy, and you can
see that the image has power, but you can’t--
you can’t grab it with your rational mind.
You can’t take it into pieces and analyze
it as an argument.
And that’s what we do if we’re intellectuals,
right?
We try to understand the detailed structure
of something.
And I think the detailed structure of what
Tolstoy apprehended as optimistic is actually
comprehensible.
And we’ve been working towards that and
circling around it the entire course of this
lecture series.
But I have found with this material that with
each circling around the target, it gets clearer
and clearer.
It’s a funny thing.
It’s like you’re looking at something
that’s too complicated to see all at once.
So you have to look at it from multiple different
perspectives, and again and again.
And each time you look at it, it becomes clearer
and clearer.
And that’s still the case for me when I
go through this material.
Every time I go through it, I think: Oh yeah,
that piece fits there.
And that piece fits there.
And that’s how that makes sense.
And: Oh that’s a lot more remarkable than
I thought it was to begin with… and so on.
And it seems fundamentally inexhaustible.
And of course, that’s what you’d expect
from deep, deep stories, right?
Stories that have been around for thousands
and thousands of years, wouldn’t have been
around for thousands and thousands of years
unless they were in some sense inexhaustible.
And we’ve talked about some of the processes
that might contribute to that inexhaustibility.
So at the beginning of the lecture series,
I told you to consider the assumption that
there was more than one way of looking at
the world, right?
There was the standard materialist sort of
scientific viewpoint, which was that the world
was made up of objects – independently existent,
as among them - the objects have no intrinsic
value, one way or another.
And the issue of meaning per se wasn’t included
in that account.
And then I said: Well wait, there’s another
way of looking at the world, that we spent
just as much time developing, that we utilize
even more, and that’s the narrative…
That’s the narrative way of looking at the
world; to consider the nature of experience
rather than the nature of objects as real;
to consider your experience as real, even
though it includes things that can’t be
easily and tangibly identified – things
like emotions, which of course you find compelling,
sometimes even beyond your will.
Things like motivational states, fantasies,
ideals, all the things that compel your behaviour
and give you some sense that there’s a direction
to life.
people who study emotion and perception have
come to understand that the act of transforming
the world into something simply made out of
objects is incredibly difficult.
It’s so difficult that we haven’t been
able to design machines that can do it at
all.
It turns out also that when we look at the
world, we’re not just looking at it with
our visual systems, but we’re looking at
it with our motor output systems and our emotions.
So that, when you look at something like a
chair, which just stands there for you like
an object, it turns out that the mechanical
systems – the motor systems – that you
would use to use the chair to sit on it are
activated during the act of perception.
It also turns out sometimes that when you
look at something, especially if it’s something
you don’t understand and that it’s - and
that scares you – you actually react to
it; conceptualize it with your body and with
your emotions before you have any idea what
it is from the perspective of an object.
When you look at the world and when you think
about the world, you have to do it from a
motivated perspective and an emotionally ridden
perspective.
You can’t even see the world without being
gripped by your motivation and emotional states.
And so, the idea that rationality or perception
is somehow separate from, or super-ordinate
to perception and emotion is just wrong.
We understand now that you can’t even think
without being motivated.
You can’t see the world without being motivated.
And that means you always look at the world
through a kind of lens.
And the lens is a narrowing lens, and it has
to be because the world is so complicated,
you can’t see it all at once.
You’re only seeing tiny slices of it in
time, and tiny slices of it in space.
And even then, you have to narrow it to only
those things that are relevant to you at that
moment.
And we don’t know exactly how you do that.
We know that it takes years and years of perceptual
work in infancy, say so that you manage to
build up an object conception of the world.
That’s probably all your doing in the first
two or three years of life.
And you’re doing it constantly.
And it’s just as complicated as learning
language, say, or even more complicated.
Most of it’s invisible, and we don’t know
how children do that.
And by the time they can talk, they’ve already
done it.
So, they can’t even tell us what they’re
doing.
It takes a long time to build up an object
world.
And when you look at the world - when you
go from Point A to Point B - even when you’re
doing something as simple as looking for food
in-in the kitchen, you ignore everything about
the world that isn’t relevant to making
yourself a peanut butter sandwich, and you
focus in on those few things that are – the
refrigerator, the food, the knives, the cutlery,
and so on.
And everything else is screened out.
Then, you can’t help but look at the world
through that kind of lens.
And the lenses change and you can be in different
motivational states, and they can change because
of internal transformations.
You’re not hungry.
You’re thirsty.
Or you’re not thirsty, you’re interested
in someone.
Or somebody is telling you a story and then
you adopt their motivational framework, and
you can see the world through their eyes.
And now, we know the neural machinery for
that, and we already talked about that.
So, we can toss back and forth these motivational
frames of reference and that gives us insight
into someone else’s world.
You can look at the world endless numbers
of ways.
And what you’re trying to do it, out of
its infinite richness, so to speak, is to
pull out parts of it that are useful for you
while you’re moving from Point A to Point
B.
And this can be a chair, if you want to sit
down.
But if you want to take a light bulb out of
the ceiling, then it’s a stool, or a table.
And whether or not it’s a chair, or a stool,
or a table depends just as much on what you’re
doing as it does on what it is.
And I think that’s part of the reason why
human beings can be so infinitely creative,
right?
For us, the world isn’t fixed.
We never know what it’s going to bring forth.
So, 100 years ago, if someone would have said:
Well, you could build a machine on a wafer
a centimetre square out of sand and if you
have enough of those machines then everyone
in the world can be connected, and everyone
in the world can have an infinite library
of verbal material, right?
That’s impossible, but it-it’s not impossible.
It turns out that silica has those properties,
and we can build unbelievably powerful machines
out of nothing
And so then, that kind of makes you think
about just what this nothing that we’re
building things out of is, right?
Because it seems to be able to reveal a constant
array of properties; properties that are essentially
unlimited.
And it’s capacity to reveal those properties
seems to depend as much on our ability to
interact with it - whatever that is - as it
does on whatever the stuff is.
And we know, even from a strict object perception
of the world that the stuff that things are
made of is a lot more complicated than we
had originally presumed, even as materialists,
because materialists, realists, their philosophy
only holds down to about the subatomic level
of analysis – a deterministic worldview.
Below the subatomic level of analysis, there’s
nothing deterministic at all.
And the stuff that things are made of is so
mysterious that we can’t even-- we can’t
grasp it.
We can’t comprehend it.
So it turns out that rather than the story
world be, being dependent on the object world,
it might be the other way around.
The object world is dependent on the story
world.
And that implies at least to some degree that
the story world is actually more real, whatever
that means.
And then, I told you that, well, the real
problem of life isn’t so much “What do
you do when you’re around things that you
understand?”
The real problem of life is: “What do you
do when you encounter something you can’t
conceptualize?”
And I think a good recent example of that
was the bombing of the World Trade Towers,
which people were compelled to watch over
and over and over and over.
And if you ask someone: Well, what is it that
you’re watching?
They would say: Well, I’m watching the World
Trade Towers fall down but then, you might
say: Well, why are you watching it over and
over?
And they would say something like: Well, I
can’t believe it.
I can’t believe it’s happening.
And what does that mean?
It means something like: Whatever it is that’s
happening here - whatever’s being blown
apart – exceeds my ability to model.
And as a consequence, I have to expose myself
to it again and again and again, and again,
to try to understand what’s falling.
Like, what’s falling exactly?
Is it just the towers?
Is it 20,000 people?
Is it the financial system of the U.S.?
Is it the stability of the western world?
Is it the beginning of World War III?
Or as the former CIA director just mentioned
in the U.S.: The beginning of World War IV.
What is it exactly that you’re looking at
when something happens that you don’t understand?
And then you say: Well, how do you react to
that?
And it turns out that you react mostly with
your body - not with your mind, not with your
perceptual systems, not with your thoughts
– but with your emotions and your body.
And that means you sweat, and you panic, and
you feel depressed, and you feel hurt, and
you feel ashamed.
And you’re prepared for a catastrophe, which
is stress.
And all that’s basically non-cognitive and--
What that kind of means is that, when you
encounter something you don’t understand
the first manner in which you conceive of
it, is embodied; emotional, physical, way
before you develop up an object representation,
or a cognitive representation.
You may not ever get it.
Like, an event like that, or a worse event,
can throw someone into a tailspin that’s
so extreme that they never get out of it.
So you’ll see, for example, sometimes – and
this is more true among elderly people if
their spouse dies – the probability that
they’ll die in the next year - say, from
a heart attack or something like that – increases
substantially.
Why is that?
It’s because their conceptual frame was
so dependent on the existence of their spouse
– say, someone they’ve lived with for
25 years – that the anxiety and uncertainty
caused by their own anomalous disappearance
– their death is so extreme – that it
sends their body into a physiological state
that’s basically unbearable.
And that does them in.
And when you start to understand what having
your preconceptions rattled really means,
then you also start to understand why people
are so motivated to protect their ideological
territory, right – ideological territory--
that’s how you see the world.
That’s your story.
And you can’t have your fundaments rattled
all the time because it throws everything
into chaos, and that puts you in this terrible,
panicky, cortizol-ridden, stressful state
that’s really hard on you physically.
So we know for example that if you’re in
a state where you’re chronically exposed
to threat or punishment, which is the case
in depression, say, you produce a lot of cortizol,
which is a stress hormone, and cortizol is
toxic.
So the more of it you produce, the more you
kill off your hippocampus cells, and you really
need them because they’re a key to memory.
You do in your immunological system-- there’s
all sorts of negative side effects of cortizol
poisoning - increase incidents of cardiovascular
disease, heightened rate of cancer.
Plus, it’s just no fun, right?
It’s the worst thing that can possibly happen
to you, essentially.
If something unknown happens to you and blows
your frame of reference, right – knocks
you for a loop, sends you to the underworld,
however you want to construe it – that’s
really going to upset your bandwagon and throw
you into a state that you’d do virtually
anything to avoid.
But by the same token, there is a possibility
that inside that chaotic nest, there’s something
you really need.
And what’s the logic there?
Well, the logic is something like this: When
you look at the world, you only see a fragment
of it.
And that’s good because it’s pretty overwhelming,
and a fragment’s generally more than enough.
But all the information that you’ve ever
gathered in your entire life – to build
yourself out of, and to make your life stable
– has come as a consequence of your ability
to explore what you don’t understand.
And that’s an unlimited capacity, right?
No matter how much you explore and how much
information you gather, there’s always the
possibility that there’s way more information
out there.
And that means, if you have a problem and
you see that it’s a problem, even though
that’s frightening, it’s also a gateway
into a domain of possibility; and the possibility
is this richly informative background that
could, in principle, provide you with any
answer you need
And then you can think one more thing.
And the old gods, Mars say, the god of war.
Venus, the god of love.
They're all internalized for us, right?
We know that anger's a psychological state.
Love is a psychological state.
But if we look at our great religious traditions,
Christianity say, or Buddhism, just to take
two as an example.
We still have this notion that what these
figures represent is something external.
Well you might say how primitive, right?
Just as primitive as the idea that the god
of war is something external is the idea that
this sort of figure is supposed to be something
external.
It's supposed to be something embodied, right?
It’s a story about the nature of individual
moral responsibility
So the idea is something like this, well reality
itself, the existence of things seems to depend
on the existence of a finite observer.
So that we can see things from a perspective.
If you don't see things from a perspective,
everything is the same.
There’s nothing delineated.
But if there's gonna be delineated things,
small things, insufficient things, and they're
gonna be aware, they're gonna be vulnerable
as a part of their limitation.
And so you say well, limitation is a precondition
for being.
And that means suffering is part and parcel
of being
Dostoevsky said clearly, look, I give you
all the cake you want.
You got a big house.
You got nothing to do but watch TV, right?
And propagate the species.
Are you happy?
And Dostoevsky says well no.
Why?
Well cause human beings are really fundamentally
you know, ungrateful and insane.
So if you give them some little comfortable
niche to occupy themselves with so they don't
have anything to worry about, the first thing
they're gonna do just like Adam and Eve basically
or just like Buddha, they're gonna run around
looking for the apple, looking for the snake,
looking for the trouble to smash the frame
into bits no matter how comfortable it is
just so they can get access to a little chaos
and have some fun.
And so then you think well maybe it's more
like the purpose of life isn't to avoid chaos
because we like chaos.
It’s entertaining, right?
It keeps us alert and awake.
And it gives us something to do that really
has no end.
And so maybe the answer is something more
like well forget the frame of reference.
And forget the chaos but hit the balance right
between the two, right?
So that you got one foot where it's reasonably
comfortable.
And you got one foot out there where it's
kind of exciting and dangerous.
And that's perfect.
And then you think the state you wanna attain
that makes you resistant to even the greatest
anomalies, anomalies of death say or vulnerability
or mortality is exactly that, that position,
right?
Balanced right between the forces of chaos
and the forces of order or between, between
yin and yang.
And how do you know you're there?
Cause that's what it really boils down to.
How do you know that you're there?
And then you think okay, it's pretty simple.
You watch with your eyes open, just like Solzhenitsyn
watched.
You think, I don't know everything.
So let's see what I do know.
No preconceptions.
I'm not gonna shield myself from the truth
with some second rate frame of reference.
We don't believe in those anyways cause they're
always fragmentable.
I'm just gonna watch.
So when am I not miserable?
And then you think well, I'm not miserable
when I'm interested in thing, something, I
get interested in something.
I don't exactly know why I get interested
in it.
It catches me.
And what are the, what's the phenomenology
of being caught?
I’m not self-conscious when I'm engaged
in something.
I'm more like a child, which is why children
have intonations of immortality.
I'm engaged in this process.
I don't think about myself, so I’m not self-conscious.
I lose my sense of temporality because it
seems like I can do whatever it is that I'm
doing, thing that I enjoy for hours.
And the time flies by.
And I'm not even really aware of the surrounding
world.
And none of my existential concerns are paramount
at that time.
Every need is suppressed by my engagement
in the activity.
And then you say to yourself well, yeah, that
only happens like you know, ten minutes every
three days or something when I'm being particularly
miserable.
But you might say well the fact that it happens
at all is probably worth paying attention
to.
I mean if you believe that your experience
is real, like real, the fact that you can
get into a state like that at all is worth
paying attention to.
And so then you might say well that's, that's
where you're sense of ethics really starts
to arise.
what makes you interested?
Well it might be just as cracked and, and,
and peculiar as something you could possibly
imagine, right?
Your parents are against it.
Your friends are against it.
Even you’re against it when you’re thinking
clearly.
But there's still this reality that something
compels you.
And then you think well can you trust it?
And I think well that's a tough question because
I read a long time, for a long time I read
accounts of serial killers.
Cause I was really interested in what motivated
them, right?
And they’re an interesting breed in many
ways, which is why there's such a popular
fascination with them.
And you think geez, maybe you can't trust
your interest, right?
Maybe it'll take you somewhere you don't wanna
go, like seriously where you don't wanna go.
How do you know that if you really let yourself
be who you could be, that you'd end up somewhere
good.
And so then you come to the second part of
the story, which is something like this; let's
say that you’re a very, very, very finely
tuned biological machine, right?
Akin to a computer.
And then you say okay, you take a computer
and you feed it false information.
What do you get out?
False information, right?
Well you’re stuck with this computer.
It's very complicated.
You kind of reside in it in some manner you
don't understand.
And yet, you’re prone on occasions either
to deny the information altogether when you
walk away from something you know you shouldn’t
walk from.
Or to feed it bad information.
And so then what if it, what if this was the
case?
What if it was the case that the systems that
orient you with regards to your interest can
become pathologized by any relationship you
have with yourself that's predicated on bad
faith?
And so then you think well, that's why there's
an ethical aspect to this redemptive process.
Like a real strenuous and strict ethical aspect
that goes something like this;
There are things that you can do, find yourself
engaged with the world at such a level that
your existential concerns could disappear.
And we can even understand that biochemically
to some degree because if you're really interested
in something you got a dopamine release an
exploratory dopamine release.
That’s great.
I mean that's associated with positive affect,
with confidence, with increased immunological
functioning, with better memory functioning.
With learning.
Everything you want.
It's also potently anxiolytic and analgesic,
which means that if you're really pursuing
something that's compelling to you, you're
much more resistant biochemically to punishment,
disappointment, depression, pain, threat,
etcetera.
And it's not cause you're blind.
It's not cause you're blind.
It's cause your nervous system is optimally
tuned to make you maximally resistant.
And so then you might think if you were optimally
tuned, how resistant would you be?
You don't know, right?
Cause it's in a spiral that never stops moving
uphill.
We don't know what the upper end is.
And we have exemplars that might indicate
what that upper end could be.
But we don't actually know.
So then you think okay, well here's the here's
the rule, say, something like this.
If you look at the world from this perspective,
which is something you have to decide if you're
you know, you find compelling and reasonable,
the rule is this; you're always gonna run
into anomaly, right?
And anomaly’s always gonna look, look to
you like, like this.
And
it's no bloody wonder you wanna run away from
that.
I mean in some ways your whole body's telling
you watch out, and for good reason because
it's no joke.
But then there's more to the story because
the anomalous thing, that's everything you
don’t know.
you might say well, you're going out with
someone and you wanna have a long term relationship.
They betray you.
How could there be any good in that?
That's certainly what you're gonna ask when
you first encounter the unexpected information
But then you might think could be that I'm
a little too naive for my own good.
Right?
People pull me in a little more than they
should or I'm not sufficiently careful when
I enter into a relationship with people.
Or I don't treat people right.
Or I don't have a good conceptualization of
myself.
Or I'm chasing after the wrong person.
Well that's all gonna be very annoying to
learn.
But if you don't learn it you're gonna be
in big trouble.
So maybe the best thing to do when an anomaly
of that sort hits you is to think okay, yeah,
it's a dragon.
No doubt it will eat me.
But if I don't let it eat me then there'll
just be another one waiting around the corner
and it'll probably be a little bit bigger.
And if I get eaten by enough of them, I'm
not really gonna wanna be around much.
And maybe I'm not gonna be willing to help
other people be around much either.
Doesn’t seem like a very good alternative
to me.
So back in 1957, some new Gnostic writings
were discovered in a, in a cave.
They were discovered by these two Arab guys
who went out to kill the man who killed their
father.
They took him out into this cave and they
killed him.
And when they were burying him they found
these amphora full of papers and papyrus.
And they took them home.
And their mother used a bunch of them to light
cooking fires with.
And one day one of their friends who was an
antiquities dealer showed up.
And he said you know you shouldn't be burning
those.
Those are about fifteen hundred years old.
And they look like very early Gnostic gospels
And the Gnostics were this branch of Christianity
that was pretty violently suppressed by the
emergence of Orthodox Christianity.
And the Gnostics believed that faith was a
good thing but knowledge was all right too.
And they wrote gospel accounts say of Christ's
life that were knowledge predicated as much
as revelation predicated say.
And this is one of the quotes from one of
those gospels, the gospel of Thomas, which
is actually one that, the only one that got
out.
Carl Jung got a hold of them, interestingly
enough.
And this is one of the quotes.
And I really like this.
This is a non-canonical saying of Christ.
And the saying is: “if you bring forth what
is within you what you bring forth will save
you.
If you do not bring forth what is within you,
what you do not bring forth will destroy you.”
And I think that's a pretty good line to close
off the class.
So thank you for attending.
(clapping) (End)